У перші дні війни багато хто в Україні був розчарований повільною реакцією Європи.
ЄС справді відомий своєю швидкістю черепахи, а радше навіть 27 черепах, зв'язаних докупи,
адже домовитися між собою мають аж 27 держав.
Але буквально за лічені дні навіть бюрократична машина ЄС запрацювала в турборежимі.
Ось які конкретні кроки для підтримки України й ізоляції Росії уже були зроблені.
Війна Росії проти України змусила Європу діяти всупереч звичним правилам.
Уперше в історії Євросоюз виділить країнам-членам кошти на купівлю і поставку летальної зброї в Україну.
На це виділили 450 мільйонів євро. Ще 50 мільйонів підуть на захисне спорядження та пальне.
Змінив категоричну позицію щодо постачання зброї і Берлін.
Для повоєнної Німеччини це історичне рішення:
Берлін надає Києву тисячу одиниць протитанкових озброєнь, пів тисячі "Стінгерів".
Також ФРН дозволила й іншим країнам надсилати Україні зброю німецького виробництва.
Найбільшу збройну підтримку Україні надають Сполучені Штати Америки.
Додатково Білий дім виділить ще 600 мільйонів доларів на зброю для України.
Тим часом у НАТО пообіцяли передати Києву системи протиповітряної оборони.
З Польщі вже прибули вантажівки з боєприпасами, очікуються "Джавеліни",
міномети, безпілотники і стрілецька зброя.
Допомагають також Бельгія, Нідерланди, Чехія, Латвія, Люксембург, Данія.
Загалом 27 країн уже погодилися надати військову допомогу.
Стовідсоткового відключення Росії від SWIFT наразі не відбулося.
З міжнародної платіжної системи найближчим часом виключать лише окремі російські банки.
Які саме - поки невідомо. Ці фінансові установи не зможуть робити
міжнародні перекази, розрахунки за експорт та імпорт.
До того ж, ЄС і Велика сімка залишили двері відкритими:
до переліку виключених зі SWIFT банків можуть будь-коли доєднати й решту.
Західні держави домовилися заморозити активи російського Центробанку.
Це означає блокування міжнародних резервів на суму 643 мільярди доларів.
Тобто підтримувати рубль валютою Центробанк не зможе.
А російська валюта вже опустилася до історичного мінімуму.
Крім того, через західні санкції проти Центробанку і ще одного найбільшого російського банку ВТБ,
росіяни не можуть розраховуватися їхніми картками за кордоном.
А всередині країни заблоковані сервіси Apple Pay та Google Pay.
Навіть нейтральна Швейцарія вже вирішила заморозити активи понад трьохсот підсанкційних росіян.
А може заморозити і весь російський капітал в країні. Це 15 мільярдів швейцарських франків на рахунках росіян.
32 держави закрили свій повітряний простір для Росії. Це весь Євросоюз, США, Великобританія, Канада.
Російським літакам заборонено не просто сідати в аеропортах цих держав,
а навіть пролітати над їхньою територією.
А російські туристи застрягли за кордоном, їх намагаються доправляти додому через Туреччину, Єгипет і ОАЕ.
Подорожі світом для них тепер під питанням: візового спрощення в ЄС для росіян більше не буде.
А кілька країн, зокрема й популярна серед туристів Чехія, більше не видаватимуть їм візи.
Міжнародні партнери виділили Україні понад півтора мільярда доларів США фінансової допомоги.
Про це повідомили в українському уряді.
Адміністрація Джо Байдена надіслала запит в Конгрес на 6,4 мільярда доларів
для надання Україні фінансової і гуманітарної допомоги.
З 300 мільйонів євро, які виділила Франція, частина також піде на стабілізацію економіки.
Крім того, Нацбанк веде перемовини з МВФ щодо економічної підтримки.
Польща, Словаччина, Угорщина, Румунія від самого початку війни в Україні відкрили кордони для українців.
Виїхати можна без закордонного паспорта й тесту на ковід.
Для людей організували тимчасові центри, медичну допомогу й харчування.
У Німеччині, приміром, готуються запровадити тимчасовий прихисток для українців терміном до трьох років
- без потреби офіційного отримання притулку, але з правом на роботу,
отримання медичної допомоги, шкільної освіти для дітей тощо.
Також готові розмістити в себе українських біженців Сполучені Штати.
На тлі війни з Росією український уряд виступив за приєднання до ЄС
за спрощеною процедурою - якомога швидше.
Польща, Балтійські держави, Словаччина, Ірландія заявили, що таку ініціативу підтримують.
А голова Єврокомісії Урсула фон дер Ляєн виступила зі знаковою заявою:
Брюссель хоче бачити Україну у складі ЄС. "Вони - одні з нас, і ми хочемо, щоб вони були з нами", - наголосила вона.
Щоправда, конкретних термінів фон дер Ляйєн при цьому не назвала.
Європейці гучно підтримали Україну. У Берліні на демонстрацію вийшли до півмільйона людей.
У Кельні замість традиційної карнавальної ходи тисячі людей доєдналися до акції на підтримку України.
Багатотисячні мітинги пройшли по всій Європі, у США, Канаді, навіть у Мексиці й на Шрі-Ланці.
А на рахунок Нацбанку люди з усього світу надсилають гроші для української армії.
За одну добу українці й іноземці разом зібрали 300 мільйонів гривень.